edc taking over the las vegas motor  speedway this weekend of course nate  will be talking about the traffic issues  related to that but one of the  festival's biggest artists elenium was  at the billboard music awards over the  weekend and he told us his plans for edc  trying to figure out what i can play and  can't play in terms of my new stuff but  it'll be fun no matter what  [Music]  indeed well the newest billboard music  award winner will be performing at edc  sunday at the kinetic field hundreds of  artists can play nine stages for more  than 300 000 eager fans yeah i'm just  working on my new stuff throwing some  old stuff and some new stuff and okay  edc week is also going to take over our  night clubs hakkasan is hosting alesso  tyga and loud luxury omnia has a lenum  working on his new stuff back along with  martin garrix and armin van buren  zuke at resorts world has dead mouse and  g-eazy that's a line up for sure  all right